bonsoir je suis ravie d'être parmi vous
ce soir et je suis géographe je suis
géographe et au risque de vous décevoir
je ne connais pas toutes les capitales
ni tous les fleuves du monde en revanche
je travaille avec des cartes et quand je
regarde une carte et un territoire
j'essaie de comprendre comment les gens
se sont installés pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
se sont installés là comment est-ce
qu'ils ont fait de ce cette portion de
terrain un lieu de vie un lieu de
travail un lieu de loisirs bref un
territoire
je suis pas venu vous montrer des cartes
ce soir j'aurais pu mais j'ai décidé de
venir vous parler de la reconstruction
post catastrophe et de comment est-ce
qu'on s'adapte comment les sociétés
s'adaptent en face de reconstruction
post catastrophe
je suis sûr que les termes de
reconstruction de relèvement de
réhabilitation de réparation par la
touche et à chacun que ce soit par
rapport à des choses que vous avez
vécues vous individuellement ou par
rapport à des éléments qu'on vous a
rapporté on peut penser à la perte d'un
être cher à la maladie à des conflits
armés qui sont d'actualité aussi à des
catastrophes dites naturelles
et j'ai bien dit dites naturels parce
qu'il y a un vieux débat dans la science
des risques qui met en avant le fait que
les catastrophes ne sont pas naturelles
la source l'origine peut être naturelle
mais la conséquence qui devient une
catastrophe c'est lié à nos sociétés à
notre implantation sur un territoire
prenez par exemple le cas d'un
tremblement de terre si vous avez un
tremblement de terre qui se produit en
plein désert est-ce qu'on parle de la
même manière d'une catastrophe que si ce
produit sur un espace qui est aménagé
habité occupé par des communautés des
individus
en effet c'est pas tout à fait la même
le même type de catastrophe c'est pas
tout à fait le même type de d'événements
qui se produit or population humaine
hors territoire humain
plus précisément je suis donc venu vous
parler de la reconstruction post
catastrophe et la reconstruction post
catastrophe elle peut s'entendre à
beaucoup de de domaines d'applications
différentes que ce soit des risques des
catastrophes naturelles mais aussi des
conflits des guerres des traumatismes et
un des une des caractéristiques de cette
phase de reconstruction post catastrophe
c'est qu'elle comporte en elle de
nombreux espoirs et de nombreux attentes
au premier rang desquels celui de se
relever moins vulnérable c'est à dire
résilient c'est donc de cette forme
d'adaptation que je suis venu vous
parler ce soir
pour commencer mon travail sur la
reconstruction post catastrophe je me
suis posé une question quand est-ce
qu'elle démarre et quand est-ce qu'elle
s'arrête
en terme de points de départ c'est assez
facile de poser une borne c'est à dire
que la reconstruction fait suite à la
gestion de crise et que une fois que les
secours partent d'un territoire c'est à
dire que les personnes ne sont plus en
danger que leur intégrité physique et
assurée n'est plus mise en danger et
bien là démarre cette période de
reconstruction
mais cette période de reconstruction
elle est marquée au tout début du
processus par ce qu'on appelle une
compression temporelle c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a une grande quantité pardon
d'action à mener en même temps sur un
territoire de manière très rapide il y a
une grande quantité de décision à
prendre une grande quantité de d'actions
à mener il faut nettoyer enlever les
gravats ici vous avez des illustrations
de voiture et puis de bateaux un peu
plus bas dans le cadre d'un cyclone
trouver des lieux où stocker ses gravats
c'est déchets de la catastrophe et puis
il faut trouver des solutions d'abord
temporaires pour reloger ceux qui ont
tout perdu des solutions qui peuvent
être un peu précaires et puis très vite
il faut s'engager dans des solutions
plus permanentes où on va tenter donc de
reloger de manière plus durable les
populations qui ont été sinistrées
pour réaliser ce travail j'ai mené mon
baluchon mon sac à dos depuis une petite
dizaine d'années de la France
métropolitaine à l'Indonésie au Japon en
passant par les Antilles pour aller voir
comment sur les territoires les gens
s'étaient relevés comment est-ce qu'on
avait reconstruit après des grandes
catastrophes
ce travail il a été composé
principalement de d'enquêtes de
rencontres avec les personnes qui ont
fait la reconstruction c'est-à-dire les
gens qui ont fait le territoire que
j'avais sous les yeux au moment où j'y
étais
ces rencontres elles m'ont permis
d'identifier plusieurs types
d'adaptations qui ont été mis en place
des adaptations qui touchent à la fois à
l'aménagement du territoire qui touche à
la fois leur restructuration des modes
de vie des communautés mais aussi des
adaptations qui touchent sur mode de
prise de décision à la gouvernance des
risques de l'environnement et des
territoires de manière plus générale
je vous le disais en introduction dans
la reconstruction post catastrophe on a
un idéal un objectif c'est de se relever
plus résilient de limiter la
reproduction des vulnérabilités
et bien cette limitation de la
reproduction des causes de la
vulnérabilité
elles fonde la théorie du bilbach better
le bill back better c'est quoi c'est
reconstruire en mieux faire mieux que ce
qu'on avait avant et dans mes travaux
j'ai essayé d'identifier des piliers qui
feraient ce bill back better qui ferait
cette reconstruction en mieux cette
résilience collective
j'en ai identifié trois qui
interagissent et que je vais vous
présenter maintenant
le fondement de ce travail ça a été
aussi de se poser la question de est-ce
qu'on souhaite revenir à l'état d'avant
est-ce qu'on souhaite revenir à un état
normal à une norme cette
expression qui est très répandue dans le
milieu de la gestion des risques pour la
pause catastrophe qui est de revenir à
la normale est-ce que c'est vraiment
est-ce qu'on a intérêt est-ce que c'est
vraiment notre volonté de revenir de
reconstruire à l'identique tout ce qui a
été détruit et finalement tout ce qui
faisait partie des causes de notre
vulnérabilité
et bien pour penser cette reconstruction
différente j'ai donc identifié ces trois
piliers le premier il est en lien avec
la construction des bâtiments des
infrastructures et en lien avec nos
manières de d'aménager les territoires
en post catastrophe quand les bâtiments
étant ont été détruits pardon il y a une
possibilité c'est de reconstruire plus
solide plus résistant en lien avec les
forces des catastrophes qui sont
associées par exemple je pense aux
constructions par la sismiques ou par
acyclonique
il y a une autre possibilité qui est
celle de délocaliser des enjeux c'est à
dire réaménager le territoire repensé
nos modes d'organisation
alors là de localisation elle peut être
intéressante et elle est mise en place
des fois quand on estime que un enjeu
est trop dangereux trop dangereux pour
le type d'activité qui est exercée ou
trop dangereux pour ses occupants pour
les habitants
en France on a un processus un
dispositif qui nous permet de proposer
aux habitants de ces maisons là de ces
enjeux-là un rachat de leurs biens pour
qu'ils puissent se reloger ailleurs hors
zone à risque
c'est très bien mais il y a des enjeux
qu'on peut pas déplacer et puis il y a
des territoires ou si on envisageait
d'enlever tous les enjeux qui étaient
exposés à un ou plusieurs risques et
bien en fait on viderait complètement en
territoire de ses habitants et de ses
activités
alors on protège alors on adapte on
construit des digues des murs anti
tsunami par exemple on construit des
barrages qui sont efficaces jusqu'à un
certain seuil jusqu'à un certain stade
au-delà duquel ils ont pas été conçus
pour résister
il y a donc d'autres types de mesures
complémentaires qu'on peut mettre en
place en termes d'aménagement du
territoire qui répondent aussi à des
besoins d'attractivité de ces mêmes
territoires je pense par exemple aux
solutions fondées sur la nature qui sont
des éléments de génie écologiques qui
sont connus depuis des années et qui
vont permettre en même temps qu'on
améliore la qualité de vie des habitants
de limiter les risques de ruissellement
par exemple c'est à dire qu'on peut
avoir au lieu de bétonner et d'avoir des
zones complètement imperméables
l'intégration d'espaces verts de parc de
noms qui vont permettre d'infiltrer
d'augmenter la capacité d'infiltration
des sols et de fait de limiter ce risque
de ruissellement
les habitations les infrastructures
c'est bien mais elles sont au service
des populations alors je suis désolé
c'est un petit peu coupé mais c'est pas
très grave
les populations du coup on essaye
collectivement et individuellement de
soutenir l'effort de relèvement les
forces de reconstruction post
catastrophes ça va des petites entre
guillemets actions de solidarité et des
hauts nettoyage aider à la gare de
d'enfants à aller chercher des
victuailles des vivres de la nourriture
de l'eau par exemple ça va aussi
jusqu'aux aides plus importantes en
termes de montant en termes de quantité
et je pense aux aides de l'État par
exemple qui ont été mises en place aussi
pendant la crise covid notamment pour
permettre aux individus aux salariés de
continuer à avoir un revenu et pour les
entreprises leur permettre soit le
maintien d'activité quand c'était
possible soit de survivre malgré l'arrêt
de l'activité et de préparer la reprise
d'activité après
il y a aussi une autre possibilité une
autre alternative c'est par exemple si
on pense à des territoires qui ont un
seul mode de fonctionnement économique
une mono économie touristique c'est le
cas dans la plupart de nos îles des
Outre-mer
quand on a ce mode de fonctionnement
fonctionnement qui en plus très
vulnérable aux catastrophes naturelles
si vous avez une mono économie
touristique et un cyclone qui passe sur
une île l'ensemble des infrastructures
sont sinistrées ou détruites et de fait
l'activité économique totale de l'île
s'arrête puisqu'on a plus de touristes
plus d'infrastructures pour les
accueillir alors il y a une possibilité
de diversifier les moyens de subsistance
d'aider par le biais de formation de
reconversion les individus à diversifier
leur mode de vie pour être moins
vulnérable en cas de crise
je vous parlais de financement et de
d'argent en France en effet après les
catastrophes naturelles c'est la plupart
du temps l'État qui vient en large
majorité apporter des fonds pour
reconstruire les territoires et relever
les sociétés
cet argent public il a des lois des
règles de distribution des règles de
diffusion c'est-à-dire que il faut
mettre en concurrence les entreprises
pour avoir le prix le plus juste
possible par exemple il y a différents
types de règles comme ça qui sont liées
à la dépense de l'argent public on ne
peut pas dépenser n'importe comment
l'argent public or ces règles elles sont
longues elles sont chronophages elles
prennent beaucoup de temps à être mise
en place et il faut passer d'un
ministère à l'autre pour avoir les
différentes autorisations et ce que j'ai
observé dans la phase de post
catastrophe c'est que systématiquement
après des catastrophes majeures on avait
une réorganisation une restructuration à
l'échelle locale et nationale de la
gouvernance et de nos modes de prise de
décision sur les territoires c'est à
dire qu'on va avoir une un mode de
gouvernance interministérielle on va
arrêter de penser en silo le social d'un
côté le logement de l'autre l'écologie
de l'autre et l'environnement encore
ailleurs on pense les choses de manière
globale
et cette capacité à se restructurer à se
réorganiser en post catastrophe elle est
liée aux besoins de répondre rapidement
aux besoins des sinistrés et de dépasser
de fait ces procédures qui sont longues
et chronophages administrativement et
elle montre aussi notre capacité à
fonctionner autrement
parce que on a l'impression quand on est
dans le temps normal hors phase de
reconstruction post catastrophe qu'on ne
pourrait pas fonctionner autrement que
comme on fonctionne que tout est
tellement
ankylosé qui a une telle inertie du
système qu'on serait pas capable de
fonctionner différemment or la période
de reconstruction poste catastrophe avec
le besoin qu'elle a de faire travailler
les gens ensemble autour du territoire
et de la société nous montre qui a cette
capacité de réorganisation qui est
réelle existante et que ça fonctionne
alors vous me direz selon ce schéma à
force de catastrophes et de
reconstruction et bien en fait on
deviendrait complètement résilient d'un
coup sur l'autre on aurait réduit la
vulnérabilité d'avant et puis on serait
prêt en fait et on serait complètement
et totalement résilient au bout de
quelques galoper c'est finalement
c'est un peu plus compliqué que ça vous
vous en doutez
en effet la reconstruction elle part pas
d'une page blanche elle part pas d'un
état 0 elle se fonde sur ce qui était
avant sur ce qui existait avant la
catastrophe sur ces modes de
fonctionnement qui sont à la fois nos
causes de vulnérabilité nos sources de
vulnérabilité mais qui sont aussi les
fondements de nos capacités d'adaptation
futures
alors cette adaptation certes elle peut
se mettre en fin en place en période
post catastrophe mais elle peut aussi se
développer se mettre en place dans des
temps calme hors temps de reconstruction
pour ce faire ça nécessite de choisir
qu'on va investir de l'argent public du
temps sur un objet qui est virtuel le
risque quelque chose qui n'est pas
encore concrétisé
la phase post catastrophe on peut la
considérer comme une fenêtre
d'opportunité pour mettre en place ses
adaptations parce que justement les
dommages les destructions ont révélé ont
donné à voir les vulnérabilités du
territoire à la fois structurelle mais
aussi organisationnel cette prise de
conscience elle est utile et elle est
moteur pour des petites adaptations qui
se mettent en place progressivement
le concept que j'ai développé dans le
cadre de mes travaux de thèse et puis
après c'est le concept d'une
reconstruction qui soit éthique et
préventive c'est-à-dire qu'elle va
mettre en place des mesures qui vont
permettre un accès plus juste aux
ressources pour tous réduire la
marginalisation donc des principes de
justice sociale et territoriale
mais aussi des mesures de prévention des
risques actuels et futurs et sur ce
point particulier
reconstruire différemment c'est aussi
résister aux incertitudes parce que
d’accord on va reconstruire différemment
mais qui nous dit qui nous garantit que
cette reconstruction différente va
vraiment nous permettre de réduire nos
vulnérabilités et si elle le permet pour
un type de catastrophe est-ce qu'elle va
le permettre pour l'ensemble des autres
types de catastrophes auquel on est
exposé l'ensemble des autres crises
auxquelles on est exposé
alors j'ai envie de faire référence à un
grand monsieur de la pensée de la
gestion des crises Patrick Lagadec pour
pas le nommer qui nous disait il y a
quelques années que pour gérer les
crises et les catastrophes il fallait
finalement se préparer à ne pas être
prêt se préparer à être surpris
mais se préparer à être surpris à ne pas
être prêt ça ne veut pas dire ne rien
faire et attendre que ça arrive ça veut
dire mettre en oeuvre l'ensemble de nos
moyens et de nos ressources pour réduire
les vulnérabilités qu'on a identifiées
celles qu'on connaît tout en étant
conscient que potentiellement il y a
d'autres vulnérabilités qu'on n'a pas
identifié qu'on n'avait pas vu venir qui
vont émerger peut-être des prises de
décision qu'on aura eu là peut-être de
l'interaction avec d'autres types de
causes de vulnérabilité bien plus
ancienne que les décisions de
reconstruction
alors pour finir je voudrais vous dire
un tout petit mot sur l'adaptation au
sens large et citer cette citation de
Darwin qui a été choisie par les
organisateurs du tadx aujourd'hui et qui
était la citation de clôture de ma thèse
qui dit que les espèces qui survivent ne
sont pas les plus intelligentes ni les
plus fortes mais celles qui s'adaptent
merci
[Applaudissements]